the ois incident  this is video of him off the freeway  driving through the  neighborhoods approaching carry wrong  way of travel here  crossing over the uh for the right side  of travel still northbound fifth through  carry  heavy traffic now uh cheyenne he's going  off her right  [Music]  looks like he's uh trying to get around  our vehicles now  um continue on trying to rock  a way of travel 70 miles an hour  traffic's getting a little bit heavier  here i'll be up so  trying to change the lanes of travel  they're gonna get stuck air units unless  they uh  smash through cars looks like they did  uh by the side swept some vehicles there  craig road  okay this is the video of the  termination of the pursuit they're going  to be trying to bench canines up  short medical please 15 self-centered  that's when the shots were fired  this is body cam video  that was some body cam video from one of  the